welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston this is a breakdown of Marvel's
secret Invasion Episode 6 the finale
home and why pick one Avenger to fight
as when you can beat all of them there's
actually a lot of interesting Marvel
Easter eggs in this episode a lot of
cool details that you might have missed
so I'm gonna break it all down our
review of the finale and the full season
is on the break room Channel and be
warned we do get pretty honest in that
conversation but you should definitely
subscribe to the break room and
subscribe to the Deep dive Channel and
you can support us with a scroll
inspired shirt at nerd riot.shop also
sagastra has informed us that
entertainment journalist Outlets like
new rockstars are okay to cover movies
and TV this is not a paid promotion my
goal with this video will be to
celebrate the craftsmanship of all the
talented artists who worked on this
title because whatever you thought about
this episode there is a lot to
appreciate here okay as in past episodes
we open with a truncated version of the
Marvel Studios title card where the word
secret from Bruce Banner's line in the
2012 Avengers movie pops out but now all
of these Avengers come under a different
context because they now represent the
blood in the mix the red and The Ledger
of the Scrolls in their Avengers Harvest
cocktail that we see this episode we
open on Priscilla walking through her
ruined house after the shootout last
episode where it looks like Grimace blew
his brains out after everyone celebrated
his birthday by drinking his blood
no no no this is just purple scroll
blood of course but this episode's title
is home and I can't imagine Vara feels
comfortable in this one anymore either
the house or this planet Nick Fury or we
think this is Nick Fury because it turns
out we were right about that fake fury
theory at least when it comes to new
skrillos one of the theories calls Vara
but the face is in Shadow the entire
scene making it hard for us to trust
this man of mystery we never really can
be sure on this series when we were
talking to Fury when we were talking to
someone else Fury ended last episode
calling someone from Finland saying
let's finish this and now we have to
assume that that was Gaia the real Fury
just went back to the UK while Gaia
pretended to be him flying from the UK
to Russia and somewhere in the middle
there there was a conversation between
Fury and Gaia about what guys should say
and where he handed off that DNA to her
Fury says that he dialed vara's number
all these years but never pressed send
maybe given their covert communication
they avoided traceable phone calls and
they agreed only to call this number
when it might be the last time they talk
to each other so really Fury could be
saying I broached a few suicide missions
in the past few years but I haven't
crossed that line until now and that
could be why Vara now says you don't
have to if you don't want to Darling now
Fury doesn't indicate where he is
exactly here I suppose to keep the
audience in doubt as to whether he's in
Russia or in the UK but Vara says that
he seems far away which I think is her
way of saying that she still feels some
distance with him meanwhile Fury uses an
empty car to Ambush the scroll guards at
new scrollos this looks like a different
gate than what we saw when Beto joined
the group in episode one so maybe Fury
is trying to sneak in a back way if
graphic wanted Fury to bring the Harvest
and to chat with him for a bit I don't
know why he would let armed guards shoot
at the car but either way since we know
that this is Gaia actually we have to
assume that she knows that she's under
graphic surveillance which is why she
approaches as Fury seriously the Oscar
goes to Gaia this episode for all the
convincing staggering and coughing and
zigzagging as if radiation is actually
affecting her when it's not because
she's a scroll also her remorselessness
double tapping the guard after he had
already reverted his scroll form and his
death in president britson's hospital
room Colonel Rhodes AKA rava makes her
case to bomb Russian soil while the
joint Chief chairman her Insignia is
that of the U.S Navy rear Admiral this
actress is Lucy Newman Williams she
advises caution and we learn the name of
the mcu's Russian leader president
vladimov this rear Admiral says we
cannot rule out the possibility of a
false flag attack did you take a stupid
pill with your breakfast this morning
Admiral oh my God Avenger or not no way
would Colonel Rhodes talk to the Joint
Chiefs this way rude rava make and
Roadie look like a real jackass these
episodes scroody mentions having 30 dead
Russians to prove it making me wonder if
the squirrels in the motorcade attack
who died reverted to Scrolls who would
these 30 dead Russians be I think
Brody's just straight up line here and
Aid brings in real-time satellite images
of the Russians Army in the Ukraine and
Finland borders well Russia in our world
already blew past that Ukrainian border
so you know that's kind of awkward but
an armed Finland border would further
explain why it's not the real Fury in
Russia because he just came from Finland
also Rhody wrote a speech for the
president someone in Brody's position
would never do that remarks are always
written by the communication director
speechwriters maybe the consultation for
the Press Secretary of the chief staff
but not like a national security advisor
whatever position Brody's in does ritzen
have literally no other advisors and if
no one in this room watch The West Wing
So Gaia Fury approaches the new Scroll
of space the dead scroll on the ground
remember is poor Beto whom gravic killed
after they tried to overthrow him so
Gaia is really doing her best not to
react to seeing this scroll that she
recruited now revealed is executed
inside the cafeteria she sees xerxu and
all the other dead scroll mutineers guy
slash Fury uses a radiation counter
which now in retrospect really just
seems like a prop that guy uses to know
how sick to pretend to be because right
after reading the scanner notice how she
really starts to ham up the coffin in
the limping so in the hospital Sonia
calls ravarotti to move the president
because Fury is on his way she says
really this is a ploy to keep Ritson in
play and ideally separate him from rava
but I like that Sonya doesn't actually
lie here the real Fury is on his way
Secret Service agents get darted and
quickly dragged into rooms out of view
we don't really see he's doing it but
presumably it's Fury and Sony working
together because you know those agents
are probably heavy dudes guys spirit
makes their way to the Super Squirrel
machine room makes sense that she would
know her way since she's been there
before and just more great performance
art from Gaia like she fumbles the
iodine pills to make Fury look
especially weak to gravic and those
pills they're the color green you know
they are graphic asks Fury what about
that invisible cloak and shield I assume
he's referring to the Widow's Dale that
we thought Pierre used last episode but
could there be some full body armor or
shielding that Fury has used in the past
is that with a full body widow's Veil
prototype that he was talking about last
episode guy slash Fury says you're too
busy playing dress up
using my skin like a costume it's a
pretty interesting thing for Gaia to say
under the guise of Nick Fury like At
first I appreciated the line because it
seemed like Yuri was calling out gravic
for using the kind of blackface but now
we learn it's Gaia doing it while she's
really doing the same thing pretending
to be Nick Fury and graphic confirms
this was the first human I killed I
killed him because you told me to you
don't even remember yeah I think Gaia is
learning this for the first time based
off of her reaction both about graphic
wearing the first victim's face and fury
using Scrolls to murder humans graphic
implies that this human was a bit
misguided maybe he was suggested he was
a member of Hydra or some kind of
terroristic organization and gravic rage
is telling who he thinks his Fury you
look at me look at me yeah it's kind of
hard to hear a super villain say that
not think of Heath ledgers the Joker
graphic goes on all the bombs and the
blackouts and the massacres and the
wildfires and the imminent removal of
humans from their habitat that is all
you and the sad thing about this is we
don't know if graphic is referring to
thermonuclear war that might be on the
horizon or what humanity is already
going through then guy begins taking
some real Liberties monologuing as Fury
saying that it's easier to save the
lives of 8 billion people than changing
their hearts and minds and saying that
when the blip happened right before Fury
flaked off he felt relief really Gaia is
just speculating she's trying to present
the weakest version of Fury a fury that
graphic will be the most likely to pick
a fight with but this should be a tell
for us because we all saw the infinity
War post credit scene Fury was not
feeling relief there his final word was
and so Gaia slash Fury
presents the vile Carol Danvers DNA
along with the Avengers that you and
your team collected I want to talk more
about this in a second but I just can't
get past how all these DNA samples are
just loose together in one vial without
cross-contamination or total
non-viability unless they were
reconstructed into one super DNA strand
either way keep these things separate
that's why Dennis nedry had that barber
Soul can in the midst of all this is a
brief shot of U.S military personnel
being handed classified documents which
I assume is the president's order to
fire up an ICBM reviewed closely at the
receiving officer his name is Richards
maybe some relation to Reed Richards or
Nathaniel Richards or maybe I'm reaching
so graphic analyzes the DNA sample and
on his screen flash several big names
from the MCU we see ghost referring to
Ava star that phase shifting villain
from Ant-Man the WASP returning in
Thunderbolts Captain America presumably
Steve Rogers though Sam Wilson is
technically Captain America right now
corvus glaive that was the head of
thanos's black order the one with the
glaive Thanos himself an outrider that's
one of thanos's foot soldiers Proxima
midnight that was a female member of the
black order Captain Marvel then
Abomination Emile Blonsky most recently
seen in She-Hulk mantis call obsidian
Drax Korg ebony mod that was the
telekinetic priest of the black order
Frost Beast Hulk chitari remember those
were Loki's foot soldiers in the 2012
Avengers Valkyrie the Asgardian Soldier
and a current ruler of new Asgard Thor
odinson they used his first and his last
name Gamora Flora Colossus that's Groot
species and Winter Soldier now while it
doesn't show up in large text you can
see over on the side column also black
panther I don't know where during the
Battle of Earth that t'challa would have
bled like that vibranium suit seems
pretty tightly woven I'm a little iffy
about anyone having t'challa's blood
like I don't even trust the Kevin robot
to do the right thing with that but if
some mystical qualities like ebony Ma's
telekinesis get transferred over it
could also be that the powers of the
heart-shaped herbs stay in the blood as
well like I would wonder what gravic saw
in the ancestral plane when he died
probably some wakandan ancestors saying
you're wakanda get the out green
bean but if the Harvest was the mission
to acquire blood from the aftermath of
the Avengers endgame final battle would
this mean that ghost an Abomination were
present for that I I'm not so sure I
think they were just previously part of
Fury's DNA registry and he just lumped
in everything he had in this vial I also
have to question why the Scrolls list
these individual superhero monikers and
not their more commonly known MCU names
to be more specific about it like for
example they write Captain America
instead of Steve Rogers but technically
in the MCU currently kept America Sam
Wilson they also write Winter Soldier
instead of James Buchanan Barnes when
there were actually multiple Winter
Soldiers at some point Thor odinson was
specified since the status of Thor can
move on from individuals like Jane
Foster and Beta Ray Bill it's just
inconsistent but really I think the goal
is maximum hype for the most
recognizable names in the MCU in a final
episode Showdown that would cycle
through as many MCU power sets as
possible and in that regard this episode
doesn't disappoint other than I think it
leaves Gaia way too powerful but we'll
talk about that later and thank you to
betterhelp for sponsoring this video
here at new rockstars we like to figure
out what makes movies work go frame by
frame to figure out what's really going
on but when we need Insight on what's
really going on with ourselves we use
better help betterhelp is the world's
largest therapy service and it's 100
online with better help you can tap into
a network of over 30 000 licensed and
experienced therapists who can help you
with a wide range of issues to get
started just answer a few questions
about what you're looking for from
therapy and what your preferences are
better help will then match you with a
therapist from their Network that's
right for you after that talk to your
therapist however you feel comfortable
whether it's via text chat phone or
video call you can message your
therapist at any time and schedule live
sessions when it's convenient for you if
your therapist isn't the right fit for
any reason you can switch to a new
therapist at no additional charge Better
Health gives you the same level of
professionalism and quality you expect
from in-office therapy but with a
therapist who is custom picked for you
more scheduling flexibility and at a
more affordable price get 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com new
rockstars that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p.com Slash new
rockstars for 10 off your first month of
therapy so let's talk about everything
that we see here graphic fires up the
super scroll machine which glows his
shirt off I guess but his default mode
here is Hulk Jacks his chin is actually
noticeably more Ridge now than it
usually is giving it more of the
appearance of Thanos meanwhile Gaia
Furies catches Graphics punch and with
her other hand if you take it frame by
frame she retracts the scroll clothes to
expose her bare arm and then turns that
arm into a Hulk arm to punch graphic
into a nearby Smoke Stack so she turns
back into her human Gaia form and
Graphics right arm has turned Groot
meanwhile it's confirm that the real
Fury was at britson's hospital so Gaia
and gravig each activate their extremist
fire healing graphic turns his non-groot
arm into an Abomination arm you can tell
from the texturing and the fact that his
ears turn into the Abomination fins that
we've seen on the redesign since Chung
Chi Gaia turns her arm into drax's arm
you can tell from the tattooing that de
patista would have on his arm but man I
gotta say the VFX just looks kind of
uncanny valley here because Emilia
Clarke's head is just way too big for
this to be Dave Batista's arm it kind of
looks like a baby Batista arm but it's
still muscular so it's just it's just
unsettling so graphic throws the car at
her but Gaia uses ghosts phase shifting
powers to phase through it it's just
pretty clever to see how Gaia thinks
differently than just how strong can she
be next graphic turns his Abomination
arm into the rocky Cronin flesh of Korg
so now he's got wood and rock which
anyone who's bleeds that allergic to
Katana knows these resources never go
together to build anything so Gaia forms
an ice sword which I suppose is the
power of a frost beast and she takes on
a Korg arm too and she stabs him through
the chest with the ice pick graphic then
turns an arm into ebony ma allowing him
to telekinetically levitate Rubble just
like ma did against Doctor Strange in
Infinity War so I guess telekinesis
lives in Ebony Ma's DNA but I think the
absolutely silliest image of this fight
is a brief shot of Gaia falling right in
front of graphic and gravic uses a big
Hulk foot to kick her just like Hulk did
to Emile Blonsky in the 2008 Incredible
Hulk film but I guess part of the
shape-shifting if you look closely is
Hulk's tattered purple shorts then Gaia
takes on a call obsidian arm while
graphic runs at her with a club City and
arm as well and just a jacked purple
Thanos arm they both activate their
Carol Danvers powers and they fly into
the sky but Gaia recognizes Brawn vs
brawn ain't working so she activates
mantis's Powers growing amantis's
antennae and putting graphic to sleep
just like mantis did to Thanos and
infinity War so between ghost powers and
mantis Powers Gaia just seems to get the
more evasive and empathic skills that
graphic doesn't think to use in Pokemon
terms he is all hydropump flamethrower
solar beam and Thunderball and not
enough agility or sleep powder gaia's
final charge of gravic uses another
subtle ghost phase shift and then she
uses the call obsidian arm to restrain a
weakened graphic and she uses some Carol
Danvers cosmic energy to blast a hole in
his stomach I love the detail that in
his lifeless eyes you can see gaia's
glowing body reflected the last thing he
sees while he's alive meanwhile back in
the hospital standoff rava Rhody goes
for Sonia's gun which is a big mistake
because he just totally out of yourself
and fury plugs rava in the head his
purple blood make him immediately clear
to Ritson who was right here so back on
the scroll base Gaia frees the human
prisoners including Rosa Dalton the art
dealer from episode 1 the female scroll
operative who had been following
Graphics since Pagan was killed and
James Rhodes the real Roadie notice how
is wearing a hospital gown and he seems
to need help walking the real Everett
Ross is also awakened and he asks Rhodey
how long he's been here I think the
implication based on the hospital gown
is that he was taken shortly after
surgery during the events of Captain
America's Civil War yikes I mean this is
a huge deal folks it would mean that
Roadie doesn't know Tony Stark is dead
he doesn't know about Thanos or the blip
or anything that happened during
Infinity war or in game it'd mean the
Roadie who Shrugged off the government
leaders in Infinity War who fought the
outriders in wakanda who was there in
the immediate aftermath of the blip who
conference called The Avengers in
endgame looking for Clint Barton who
proposed choking Thanos as a baby who
backhanded Peter Quill during the Time
Heist on Morag who fought in the Battle
of Earth and who cried at Tony Stark's
side when he died all of that was not
Roadie but a scroll named rava it would
also mean that Roadie has been here for
nearly nine years which is a lot of
exposure to radiation I'm sure we'll all
talk about the impact of this decision
by Marvel Studios if that is indeed the
case and upcoming videos on the channel
but also notice freed here is the Human
UK prime minister Pam Lawton and the
human informed that Pagan took now I'm
not sure what happens to the scroll form
of lot and presumably she slips back
into the Shadows so president ritzen
changes into a suit and makes a
televised address from its hospital room
about the motorcade attack that is why
tonight I'm presenting to Congress for
immediate emergency authorization a bill
that designates all off-world-born
species enemy combatants yikes all
off-world born species what would that
mean for the people of new Asgard with
whom ritzen signed a trade agreement as
recently as black panther wakanda
forever according to that news ticker in
that film with the asgardians have to
register with the US government or are
they automatically at war with us those
goats are gonna all over the
Pentagon off-world species would also
include all friendly Scrolls any Cree
the Guardians of the Galaxy eternals or
giant celestials who pop by for a visit
this could be why trailer footage for
the Marvels shows Nick Fury with a
variety of humanoid races in Earth's
orbit on a saber space station may be
providing a bit of Refuge from ritson's
war ritzen looks passive and reactive in
the speech leaning back away from the
camera when ideally you'd want to lean
forward and make the speech for maybe
the Oval Office or the East room of the
White House like if you just took a hit
you don't sit in your sick bed leaning
back and declare the world everyone's my
enemy and I'm gonna kill them all it's
just not a good look Fury returns home
to find the dish where they previously
kept their wedding rings now completely
shattered we could view this as a symbol
like their wedding bands remain intact
but that little covert game they used to
play where they would publicly hide
their marriage the whole point of having
wedding rings is all is to let people
know that you're taken that game that
they play is no longer in play so when
he ends the scene by still plopping his
ring in those broken shards he's kind of
inviting her to resign from that game
with him in piece this marriage back
together and I don't know if this is a
matter of editing or what but Vara is
back home now and I don't really know
the point of showing her with her go bag
was earlier was she running some errands
I actually think she was meeting with
Sonya fallsworth and showing her that
room filled with all the bodies of
humans talk about that in a second Vara
asks did you fall in love with me
or the face that puts you at ease well
guys question last episode about whether
Fury likes her in her own skin stung her
I cannot but wonder if there was still
some validity to the question and I
really like this line because it's a
question that every spouse should ask at
least themselves or each other we must
love our partners in their totality and
not just the aspects of them that make
us feel good about ourselves if we think
a healthy relationship is constant
showering of compliments and ego
stroking and anything beyond that is
toxic we're basically asking to be
infantilized Fury says I
love you Priscilla bevara says but I
guess this is goodbye Fury says I love
you Priscilla and Vara says I guess this
is goodbye then Fury doesn't pick up the
hint that she wants him to call her by
her scroll name Sonia pops out a guy
over behind a corner like she's freaking
Pennywise oh I haven't come for a fight
Gaia
with your special abilities it would be
a lopsided Affair so gaia's new power
status presents some issues for the MCU
Carol Danvers Cosmic radiation is meant
to make her the most powerful Avenger a
status that is now Complicated by The
Cosmic entanglement of the upcoming
Marvel's film when she's basically
handcuffed to Monica Rambo and Kamala
Khan swapping places with him so if Gaia
also has Carol's Powers would she also
be linked with that as well Amelia
Clarke has not been announced to appear
in the Marvel's film I don't think she's
gonna be in it but also if Gaia has all
the powers of all the other enhanced
Marvel heroes who would ever hope to
check that power so Sonia says Gaia
should step up as a new scroll leader in
that she would need resources to fight
this War written as launch notice how
Kaya wears a green jacket now and seems
ready to step up into a scroll command
but the organization that she forms with
Sonia could be in my 13 maybe Excalibur
whatever they decide to name the group
that Dean Whitman and blade are also a
part of with ballsworth leading British
intelligence this suggests a realignment
of international relations along the
interests of individual Nations and
underwritten the US is becoming
increasingly isolated this sets up a
scenario in Captain America 4 Brave New
World where the us could be at war with
several former allies like the UK I
would love to see Sonia Paul's birth
share a scene with Val because I think
those two actors are some of the best
parts of the recent Marvel titles so
Fury calls president and scolds his
hateful ass speech Yes Fury implies that
ritzen's unpopularity could result in a
new president succeeding him setting the
stage for Harrison Ford as president
Thaddeus Ross and Captain America 4.
though I gotta say based on US History
presidents who rally the public around
fears for their safety often Costa
re-election like George W Bush in 2004
with a war on terror Reagan in 1984 with
a renewed Cold War brinkmanship in the
early 80s Nixon at 72 after his beer
mongering over turbulence of her protest
movement Lyndon B Johnson in 1964
painting Barry Goldwater is a war Monger
who would escalate the Cold War to
nuclear Annihilation FDR getting
re-elected in 1944 despite being on his
deathbed because the US was fighting a
two-front World War Sonia and Gaia find
a massive room filled with squirrel pods
this is how the enemy got so good super
confusing scene it's not clear how Sonia
found this location maybe this is where
Vara was going or really based on the
dialogue we don't know what's going on
here my interpretation is that there are
far more Scrolls in hiding as humans in
Earth Society than previously realized
and that they are gradually been
learning our ways to become experts at
assimilation sharing this knowledge in a
kind of scroll hive mind still though I
really do think this was part of a
longer scene that was edited down after
reshoots because this moment as part of
an epilogue Montage just doesn't really
make sense it doesn't ask any one clear
question and it doesn't answer anything
like I highly doubt the scene was
written this way and I just don't know
why it was featured in so many trailers
other than to justify the budget to get
this visual because it does look really
cool we just don't really know what it
means I guess the question now is though
does Sonia share this scroll human nest
with ritzen does she attempt to broker a
peaceful solution with the remaining
Scrolls on Earth using Gaia and best the
CIA with a more nuanced intelligence
Network we see a Godfather style
execution Montage in which members of
the scroll Council are wiped out like
the heads of the five families a
freaking firing squad guns down the news
anchor Chris Stearns doing a broadcast
absolutely wild at these human militants
could make it all the way past security
into the studio but maybe the studio
head looked the other way and told
security to stand down so that a scroll
would be executed and outed on live TV
another assassin shoots UK prime
minister Pam Lawton but she doesn't
revert to scroll form because we saw the
human scroll get freed from the fracking
pod earlier so this assassin must have
been working on Intel that Lawton was at
one point of scroll suggesting these
Vigilantes might have captioned and
tortured one of the members of the
scroll Council an armed gunman getting
anywhere near the UK prime minister is
absolutely insane as well Downing Street
is heavily secured and limited to press
and other political VIPs so someone in
power must have let the shooter through
meanwhile former member of the scroll
Council Shirley cigar managed to fend
off the Assassins remember she was the
one that graphic allowed to leave the
council this montage is the most violent
the show has gotten and I suppose this
is what the MCU has in mind for the
status quo of Brave New World
Thunderbolts and armor Wars so in the
final scene Vara joins Fury as he
prepares to return to space Priscilla
Vara yeah Vara wants Fury to see her as
she is now Fury reports good news from
saber decree said they opened peace
talks with the Scrolls now Fury would be
referring to the cree political
establishment on holla led by the
sentient AI the Supreme intelligence I
doubt Fury would be talking about the
militant faction led by Dar Ben in the
upcoming the Marvels she wants to
destroy Earth and probably holla and
might end up toppling whatever peace
talks Fury envira tried a broker but
Vara says my work is here darling
and it's never been more important yeah
what work is referring to there was a
quick shot of a frame periodical about
Priscilla Davis's genetic research we
never really learned what Vara had been
trying to do I think she was referring
to that vast basement of all those human
bodies I think that was her operation so
a blinding beam of light from the saber
transport ship mirrors the earlier shot
from episode one this shot here
initially bisects the Two Silhouettes
the two spouses so that they start this
interaction divided by the
responsibility to keep earth and its
inhabitants safe but as Vara reverts to
her scroll appearance Fury accepts her
as she is and they kiss and together
they board the transport the light
enveloping both of them to turn their
two Shadows into one combined marriage
like Steven Spielberg's intense
backlighting on Close Encounters to the
Third Kind these earthlings and
extraterrestrials have more in common
than they do reasons for division and
while it's easy to feel divided in the
shadows of ignorance and deception and
the light of Truth we are united as one
I want to thank Noah Chan Eric Francisco
Gina ipolito and Jordan Morris for their
help writing this breakdown and their
amazing work all season long subscribe
to all three of the new rocks Stars
channels in our Network follow me on all
social platforms at eavos follow new
rockstars thanks for watching bye
[Music]